now looking forward to iOS 9 improving
performance and enhancing security to
protect customer data that's iOS not
once a year we all gather around while a
jolly white-haired man bustos gifts on
all the good little boys and girls I'm
talking about apple's WWDC Apple
announced iOS 9 which will once again
change the game with revolutionary new
features never before seen in the tech
world Apple through a lot of iOS 9 info
at us I'm drew Coolidge and I'm here to
break down the best new features of iOS
9 this is hashtag news
oh my god yup the day every iOS user has
been waiting for is finally here we have
multitask Android and Windows tablets
have been multitasking for years shhh
don't let the ghost of Steve Jobs hear
you there's an awesome new feature
called slide over which allows you to
swipe a nap over to the right side of
your screen and open another app
simultaneously so now you can interact
with your friends on Twitter while
pretending to do your homework hey I'm
talking swipe me back swipe me back
there's also a picture in picture which
will let you keep a video playing in the
corner of your screen while you work on
a different app and speaking of
procrastination you can now have an even
better conversation with Siri because
she's getting an intelligence upgrade
serious both smarter and more aware of
your habits cool yup creepy yup in iOS 9
Siri will get a new feature called
proactive this feature will allow Siri
to learn the way you interact with your
device and attempt to predict what
you're gonna do before you do it for
example if you frequently go for an
afternoon jog while listening to a
specific type of music for me african
tribal syrian will learn this behavior
and suggest more options for you boy
what if someone gets hold of this
information and uses Syria against me
there's new security options oh yeah
that's right apple also announced a new
two-factor authentication to improve
security now when you Dookie things on
your device such as making purchases on
the App Store you're required to provide
two forms of identification so now when
thieves want to access my super sexy
selfies on my iCloud photo album they'll
have to cut off my thumb and my mind
good luck it's a jungle in here they've
also stated that they will not be
collecting any personally identifiable
information we'll see we'll see
newsstand will be replaced by News which
is a super easy way to read multiple
news sources on your phone it's like
making new sexy again news pools from
all of your favorite places on New York
Times the Atlantic bone appetit
conspiracy theories com conspiracy
theories net conspiracy theories CA for
all your Canadian conspiracies maps also
got an upgrade with routing for subways
buses and other forms of public transit
take that Google Maps no way they've had
that for years well when will I be able
to get my hands on iOS 9 the public beta
testing is in July and full release is
expected sometime this fall which has me
all giddy but on the inside go ahead and
comment with which features your most
for or if you're afraid of this new
proactive series don't forget to
subscribe to new media rock stars for
all your Apple news I'm drew Coolidge
and I'm now one step closer to taking
Syria on a date Siri google which shaday
songs our best to make love to searching
google Prashad new songs our best to
make love to